i've never had a stalker like i've never
had a female stalker like
it's like okay damn yeah all right i've
had one
her she goes by the name sandy wang um
she has a website out about me no way
yeah i think it's sandywang.net
and um but i i can show you i have about
five
thou there it is yeah that's her this is
her artwork okay so this is how i got
put into this ready for this good art
so i'm out at a dog park in l.a dude
that's not that good
and this woman was walking her chihuahua
and i had my dog at the time
and she said can we take a little walk
around i had met her a couple times
she seemed normal and i was walking with
a buddy of mine
and what kind of lady white lady black
asian woman
and um we'd take one lap around the park
and she said uh
you know the twin towers exploded
because the government found a video of
me masturbating in my living room
and i was like oh now my friend was like
hey i'm out
yeah but i'm like i'm in yeah yeah yeah
so she said she said will you
go to my website here and look at my art
i'm like yeah let's see how
she also has a website basically
dedicated to
a conspiracy theory about me dang and um
so she ended up going to jail dude
did you press charges she wrote me from
jail
and she said and the letter was super
like
well written and was she attractive was
she yes
okay okay okay and so she got arrested
because she said
mercedes-benz set her up she was walking
by mercedes and i guess if you buy a
mercedes
they start the car and they leave it out
front for you so you can just
get it right so she was like well why
would they have started a car and left
it out front if it wasn't for me
so she just took a car so she just got
in and drove away
and so when she got arrested she was
like you know the system is against me
and it's an it's an asian you know it's
an asian thing and
the police were like you actually stole
stole a car
so she wrote me from jail asking for 10
000. no way
the the and what happened you hooked up
with her no
dude she this is like oh wow
this is her website yes yeah
uh so here's the emails this is the
second email i will probably not be
sending anymore anyone who says that
will definitely be saying oh my god i'll
tell you that lord dude so
look at that look at the subject oh this
three r sphincter [ __ ] rectum [ __ ]
oh come on this is too much man
really sorry what's happening in your
life but you've got to stop sending
these to me
thanks josh oh you emailed her back i
was just trying to to get out gracefully
because she was sending the
weirdest dude if i sent if i showed you
the 5 000 emails she sent me
wow do you ever see now were there
images in the emails too sometimes or no
one email was just a picture of the
house across the street from my house oh
wow
i sent about 500 of these emails to i
had a friend of mine who was in the
secret service
and i send it to him and i go am i gonna
die and he sent me back he goes no
he said she's crazy but she's like crazy
like russell crowe beautiful mind crazy
yeah
he said but none of this tells tells me
she's
um thinking about doing something
dangerous but it was crazy man this is
all
right this is all crazy writings
so was she do you in the end do you
think she was manic having like a manic
episode i had an acting class with a
girl who was having a manic episode for
like
six months on facebook and she would
post things about brad pitt
um she would post like
all kinds of crazy stories like that she
was involved in like
celebrities lives and stuff um and it
was pretty fascinating to read
but it was also really really scary you
know yeah and then i think people that
tried to reach her like she would like
lash out at them in some of her posts
you know like my dad called me today and
it was just intense man i don't know
what you do if somebody's really sick
like that
i i don't know i can tell when she's on
her meds and not on her meds
if when she's not under meds i get 10 to
15 emails a day
but they'll but i'll go three months
without getting any dude one day at my
house
on my home phone now we've always had a
home phone just because beth is like
just in case we need a home phone
but nobody has that number you know so i
get a phone call
my family has it i get a phone call and
i'm like hello and it's wang
it's worse than wang i go hello and they
said josh wolfe i go yeah speaking and
they said this is i forget what his name
this is so-and-so so-and-so the head of
tom cruise's security
and i thought it was my brother and i
just said hey dan [ __ ] you
and i hung up two seconds later same
number
and i go damn we gonna do this like tom
cruise's security this
is what you're going for hung up call
back don't hang up
i need to ask you about sandy wang now i
know my brother doesn't know about sandy
wayne
and i know there are only two people in
my life who do know me and beth oh and
jacob because i need to be like hey if
you see a short little asian woman
around the house
yeah get the [ __ ] out even though he'd
probably try to smash
jacob dude that dude is definitely
he's about some [ __ ] i mean listen
he's at that age and look i feel it yeah
he's at that age where he is still
willing here's exactly how it is
he is still willing to [ __ ] someone that
is extremely dangerous
yo we've all been that how old are you
i'm i would [ __ ] a stalker that's how
old i am
that is a 100 right that is an age
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one